[Music]
the footage appears fairly conclusive
posted on pro-russian social media and
overlaid with dramatic music it shows a
convoy of their troops snaking its way
past the city's police station
weaving in and out of the debris and
destruction caused by their attacks
as russian soldiers punched the air in
triumph
the soldiers filmed themselves waving
red flags from key city buildings
while residents shower them with
apparently grateful hugs
there are plenty of tears it's relief
we're told
and with the english subtitles already
laid on we're shown delighted residents
emerging from bunkers this was a very
clear message to the west and ukraine's
backers in the battle to win the
propaganda war
flowers are handed over to the jubilant
troops and according to this footage the
russian troops entered on saturday
we're in the center of lissy shanks he
says it's july 2nd and 3 30 p.m
we're near the sign i love lizzy shanks
he goes on we took the city without any
losses
that's not true we were inside the city
centre a few days ago and saw the body
of a russian soldier laid out on the
side of a road the ukrainian police
spread out the piles of russian army
uniforms also found
and we filmed ukrainian troops driving a
captured russian armored personnel
carrier around the city's back streets
we were inside the city's oil refinery
as the soldiers from the two armies
slugged it out
we were alongside the ukrainian soldiers
from the 24th brigade as they told us
they were taking the strategic decision
to pull back from the oil plant
there are only a few thousand residents
still inside lizzy shanks the
overwhelming bulk about 90 000 who align
themselves with the ukrainian government
have already fled west
but of those we spoke to there still
seemed just as many concerned at the
russian invasion as those who see them
as liberators
and this after years of pro-russian
propaganda
but moscow insists it's captured the
city three quarters of the center is
destroyed and says it now has what it's
calling full control over lahars one
half of the donbass
it is a significant strategic loss for
the ukrainians with the lehance governor
saying the russians used inexplicably
brutal tactics to exact their victory
there are already signs the russian army
is pushing hard further west and deeper
into the dombas industrial region
smashing the city of slaviansk on sunday
with multiple rocket launchers and
causing around 15 fires
it's the worst shelling to hit the city
recently but control over the entire
donbass is the primary goal of russia's
military operation now after its failure
to take the capital kiev early on
since then they've made steady gains in
the east as ukrainian officials and foot
soldiers we spoke to insist they're
being out gunned and running out of
ammunition we have one tank and they
have
10 tanks 15 tanks
even even
experienced soldiers can't
keep the pressure in the in the
battlefield using only one tank
and enemies when the enemies have 15.
it's it's impossible
the other city now being badly targeted
is bakmut it's also lying in the path of
russian ambitions in donetsk
this airstrike in the middle of the day
landed just 50 meters away from our
accommodation in the middle of the city
centre somehow no one was killed we know
that this is a favored russian tactic of
pounding an area fiercely from afar
before moving in closer and closer and
claiming more territory and this seems
to be a clear indication as you could
get that they're not going to stop where
they are they intend to move forward and
move into the second half of the donbass
the ukrainian forces insist they are
inflicting significant losses on their
russian enemies but they're also having
to concede valuable territory too and
this town could be next alex crawford
sky news in buckneut in the donbass